bonne nouvelle et on a quand même une le
monde des livres publie des lettres
inédites de Heinrich himler à sa femme
comme quoi il avait un cœur
j'accueille maintenant Gaspard Proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est c'est tendu hein
enfin ce rapport de force entre Philippe
Besson et Myriam Leroy c'était
bon bah bonjour ouf je vois le public
est là c'est
[Applaudissements]
votre intelligence c'est mon meilleur
soutien
non pardon c'est votre soumission s'il
vous plaît hier c'était la
Saint-Valentin et bon je lui ai fait des
choses extraordinaires
bon je parle pas d'une fécondation in
vitro c'est pas tu vois les trucs un
coup de rein contre la verrière de la
véranda enfin ce qui est le
en fait j'ai joué la classe quoi j'ai
fait envoyer une limousine à son bureau
il a emmené faire du shopping avec une
carte illimitée et puis bon super resto
on est rentré à la maison il y avait des
pétales de roses sur le sol des bougies
aux essences de figue millénaire quoi je
savais pas que ça existait bon j'en ai
une partout là forcément ça commence à
chauffer un peu elle commence à et au
moment où elle fait péter le string
claque les flics qui débarquent une
amende de 1500 euros quoi
et tu sais pas moi je l'assume mais moi
les plus belles Saint-Valentin c'est
avec des
ah oui c'est c'est
les seuls qui acceptent que je leur
fasse l'amour en disant maman je t'aime
quoi
il faut être honnête les prostituées on
s'est attention c'est intuition je
dirais presque c'est intelligent qui
fait cruellement défaut aux femmes
ordinaire elles savent d'instin qu'une
fois que tu as joui il faut y aller
c'est
comme ça
politique nationale donc référendum en
Suisse puisque je suis suisse donc
actualité nationale
alors moi c'est quand même une votation
très émouvante très enfin comme quoi
quand on choisit bien le sujet du
référendum les suisses peuvent dire oui
à quelque chose tu vois il faut nous
comprendre les Suisses c'est dur il y a
pas de chômage les salaires sont super
élevés il y a de la sécurité tout est
propre tout fonctionne la vie est
tellement chiante
pourtant canailler tu es obligé de faire
des trucs comme des Barka une soirée en
faveur des victimes de la Shoah déguisé
en 16 quoi tu vois tu es obligé je veux
dire les Suisses on peut envoyer un
signal politique non ils se sont juste
détendus c'est tout c'est tout c'est un
truc de perruche quand tu t'ennuies le
seul truc qui t'excite encore c'est
c'est de jeter des homards vivants d'un
hélico sur un camp de réfugiés au
Darfour
il faut comprendre pour nous un immigré
français c'est
un peu comme enfin comment dire nous
quand on le voit le petit français tu
sais dans sa petite Peugeot toute
pourrie là qui traverse la frontière et
les yeux qui brillent comme ça durant
peut-être qu'ici je vais peut-être
m'acheter des gens en alu un chargeur de
CD quoi tu vois
pour nous à l'immigré français c'est un
réfugié de Lampedusa avec un permis de
conduire
attention je sais ce que je dois à la
France je sais je surtout à Cazeneuve
quoi enfin en terme de les impôts là que
je vais lui filer j'espère qu'ils vont
en profiter pour prendre un styliste à
Benoît Hamon parce que
ce sont mes compatriotes sont pas
habitués en français c'est une question
de culture tu vas en Suisse quand tu
vois dans la rue quelqu'un qui se prend
une avec un Libé sous le bras les gens
ils appellent le Samu social
alors moi ça fait un moment que je suis
ici le pays commence à détendre sur moi
moi je suis arrivé si j'étais plein
d'énergie maintenant au bout de 7 ans je
suis devenu français comme vous ah ouais
j'ai peur de l'avenir et tout moi
vraiment vu les avantages dont jouissent
les fonctionnaires à la SNCF moi je rêve
de me caser avec une fille de cheminots
[Applaudissements]
à l'international pendant ce temps votre
président est aux États-Unis qu'est-ce
qui a l'air content là-bas
tu as l'impression qu'il a gagné une
Green Card à la loterie
puis super fière il roule des mécaniques
là ouais je connais baraque même je le
tutoie je lui dis you
[Applaudissements]
alors la Silicon Valley ils vont aller
faire un discours il a pris une claque
on lui a dit que caramel n'existait plus
c'était un voyage qui a duré un peu et
les States s'extasy toujours de nos
monuments et de notre passé alors nous
on s'extasie toujours devant leur futur
c'est un peu ce rapport là en gros un
américain c'est un type qui te parle de
ta grand-mère quand tu lui parles ses
petits-enfants
[Applaudissements]
pendant ce temps Sotchi les Jeux
Olympiques alors sotti Sotchi sotchip
bon les Jeux Olympiques c'est comme un
événement important c'est l'événement
planétaire aux épreuves confidentielles
ou comment faire de la mondiaux pour
faire mouiller tout un village
c'est quand même le seul véritable
intérêt des Jeux Olympiques c'est de
permettre de découvrir au 20h les
ravages de la consanguinité dans le
patelin du vainqueur
j'ai regardé un peu les chances de
médailles françaises
mec qui a gagné ou biathlon
une nana qui a gagné
franchement je crois que je ressens plus
d'émotions si j'apprends que Patrick
Menotti fait de l'apnée du sommeil tu
vois
franchement mon gosse il me dit je veux
faire du ski de fond je crois que je le
finis à coup de pêche
au 21e siècle il y a des remontées
mécaniques arrêtent tes conneries quoi à
l'école tricoter enfin s'il te plaît
même qu'on peut avoir des médailles en
curling c'est la tristesse du truc tu
imagines l'enfance du champion de
curling on dit ouais on l'a tout de
suite repéré quoi lui en classe il
regardait la femme de ménage avec envie
alors à la limite le biathlon je peux
respecter encore que je comprends pas
tout à fait le comment on peut perdre au
biathlon
au biathlon le mec qui est devant toi je
gère toi tu as un fusil dans le dos
[Applaudissements]
tu dis que peut-être que l'histoire des
cibles c'est un piège quoi
éducation toujours coopère sortie le
bouquin tout ça poêle ouais c'est son
truc en ce moment après les pains au
chocolat les livres pour enfants moi
coper ces sujets de révolte ça commence
vraiment à me faire peur je pense à
l'impression qu'il veut pas devenir
président mais directeur de crèche
shopping voiture bélier contre une
vitrine Yves Saint Laurent à Paris alors
les mecs ont piqué de la maroquinerie et
des vêtements et premier dégâts de la
théorie du genre
[Applaudissements]
bonne nouvelle et on a quand même une le
monde des livres publie des lettres
inédites de heinrichimler à sa femme
comme quoi il avait un cœur
alors elle est pas belle la vie mais
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu